So sometimes for
support vector machines, it seems impossible to do the right job.
For example, you might have a data set just like this,
in which clearly no decision surface exists that would separate the two classes.
You can think of the point down here as an outlier.
So my question for you is, what do you want support vector machines to do?
Should they give up if there's no decision surface to be found,
should they give you a random result, or should they do the best they can?
Well, it's not clear what best means, but try to find the decision surface that
best describes the data despite the fact you can't linearly separate them.